Paula Reid is at the federal district
court in Washington where Paul Manafort
and Rick Yates appeared yesterday Paula
good morning let me start with this
what's the significance of the charges
against metaphors and especially
Papadopoulos this is incredibly
significant because while the White
House can certainly try to distance
themselves from Paul manna for its
business dealings or his luxurious
lifestyle here you have a campaign aide
who has evidence that there were efforts
to set up meetings between Russia and
the Trump campaign and also has some
evidence suggesting that the Trump
campaign knew that the Russians were in
possession of some of Hillary Clinton's
emails this witness is also cooperating
and again it just completely changes the
narrative about what this investigation
is about what does the indictments in
what message does it send not only to
the Trump administration but across the
legal board well let's look at the
choreography yesterday this news leaked
out over the course of the weekend it's
several days for anticipation to build
and there were cameras lining the
sidewalks as manna court went to turn
himself in the special counsel took an
unusual step of issuing a press release
with the indictment and just as we were
through digesting all the details in
that indictment we have this bombshell
out of Chicago that not only does Muller
have another set of charges here's a
cooperating witness with evidence that
again points to this question of
conspiracy or collusion yeah to that
very point Paula he was arrested
Papadopoulos about three months ago and
he's in these additional court filings
last night he is called a proactive
cooperator what might that mean some
people have suggested that that couldn't
be in he wore a wire or has been already
cooperating and try to gain evidence at
this point my sources cannot really
establish or prove that question but
going forward it means he's going to be
a problem for the Trump White House all
right thank you very much Paul